he's on brooklyn nine-nine the one-hour
series finale airs tonight at eight
eastern time on nbc joe latrullio back
here on the show how are you joe
hey i'm great hey guys thanks for having
me what's up buddy
big night big night tonight big finale
it's a big game it's for all the marbles
guys last night back three seconds in
the shot clock here we go brooklyn
nine-nine and finale my son uh my
my oldest son zan um could not be more
excited and uh you know uh he is
as locked in on this show the whole
family is obviously but he's the one
that's great he's though he's the one um
that jay when are you gonna have joe
latulio on literally he's been saying to
me all week at
at home i gotta send them some hats
hey joe you want to give me hats i'll
take hats
whatever you got
um what can you tell us about tonight
that you don't want to review that what
are you bringing up
we uh this episode is uh really for the
fans i know um i think they're
they're gonna love what we have of
course there's a lot of spoilers i can
tell you but i can say it was quite
emotional shooting this uh last episode
which we did i guess back in june and um
you know that that last take was what it
was it was a doozy um but um i think
you know this show kind of wraps itself
up in a in a really satisfying way
and uh and you get you get the feeling
the squad um the squad will be around
squad will be on
[Music]
okay so well there's always going to be
uh necessary but i mean i say that but
that's not really a spoiler that i feel
like so many shows and would like hey
you never know
uh so but i'll stop there okay well look
there's always going to be the need of
law enforcement in in brooklyn i mean we
always know that that's right so
with a hint of comedy and humanity we we
we
there there will always be required that
um so um in terms of uh you saying this
is for the fans you could pretty much
say every damn episode is for the fans
how many times was this show saved by
the fans like could be the greatest show
ever that's been saved by the fans over
and over again
yeah the first the first big one you
know was uh you know after season five
um when we left fox and we we thought we
were done and you know for an actor you
know five seasons might as well be
fifteen you just you never know how long
it's going to go so you know we were sad
and i didn't want to end but we figured
it was over and the fans just came um
just blew up and said hey not so fast
and and brought us back and we were just
um really overwhelmed by that outpouring
and um i think since then
it's just been uh it's just been kind of
gravy uh doing the show because uh we
didn't expect to be here and
we just had a new appreciation of uh how
how much these characters were were
you know
and it ends tonight um just in terms of
the series finale i just we just got a
little bit of a bread crumb right there
from joe lo trulio eight eastern on on
nbc
so i get so many people from mbc being
what are you what are you saying what
are you doing you know uh
it'll be fun i i look forward to to all
of that so um what do you
i'm kind of feeling a little sheepish
joseph because
all last season
i was just hoping for one loss after
another after another so the jets could
get trevor
and is it possible is it absolutely
possible entirely within the realm
of planet earth and human beings and
photosynthesis and oxygen and carbon
dioxide and plants and everything
that the jets got the right guy dropped
into their lap anyway all along in zach
wilson well well per you know per are
what you're your segment that you just
played before michael we are not one to
really predict we're not not thomas's of
the jet season clearly so i'll start
there yes but uh you know i like zach um
you know it's funny uh any sandberger a
a chamber and i have a have a wager and
we've had one this entire uh run of the
series and it began the first couple of
seasons
with the over under on how many
flashbacks we were gonna go we're gonna
be in the show and we stopped in those
and then we're doing how many slow
motion you know shots will we have
what's the over under on that and
they're on season three or four we're
like let's just get the brass back and
start having a real wager here he's an
iron fan i'm a jet band and right that's
not began with you know who who are the
worst who's gonna have the worst record
because it was a while where we both
were around there and then now you know
who's gonna have the best record it
that's our wager uh the just just i i
don't think it put beat the niners this
year so
my suggestion was why don't we have a
battle of the rookie quarterbacks and
you know
starts uh and so
and realize like lance is coming in late
at some point this year you gotta expect
that um so we made a team to be
now so it's it's most team to be
um passing and rushing touchdowns for
the quarterback
and after week one it's two two
so i feel i feel i got a shot for state
dinner here
i think you do but it's it's funny you
must have been like when lance threw the
first touchdown past the 49ers season
just two snaps into their season and
zach wilson's getting beat up you must
been like come on man but and what did i
do and in case and in case anybody's
sitting out here thinking that sandberg
might be sandbagging you if this if this
bet was say
first started this wager back in 2015
which i'm just looking at the history of
your show it's entirely possible
that's when he was deep into the jim
tomsula 49ers uh era that's right right
and so just for the record yes sorry to
interrupt
i propose i propose the bet
i i was that i was a typical jet fan you
that kind of like you know what i think
we got
that's right we just got tebow we're
good
typical jets delusion yeah uh you know
we we like to fight we like and we like
the we like to scrap scrap a little bit
and uh what you know uh what'd you think
of the thumbs down thumbs up stuff from
your mets what'd you think about all
that joseph
how about that one yeah
i want that one didn't see that one
that's hard to talk it's hard to try to
talk about that
um
you know i
you know i don't know i once again i
feel like um we're we're we're snake
we're snake bit we just seem to uh not
get it together but look i love my team
um i love my team i cannot ever give up
on the match and uh you know it's that
it's that saying of uh
maybe next year maybe next year it does
look like to be the case right here so
um uh a couple more minutes left here
with joe latrulio here on the the rich
eisen show joining us on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line right here
on the program so um we had rudd on the
show the other day to help us choose our
fantasy team name
uh yeah we god bless him he stopped
being ant-man for like three seconds
over there in london to call in
um
and the two choices we gave him was
again for lines that we just throw out
every now and then was between walking
ibuprofen which i think was in reference
to
somebody ben robles yeah he's walking
ibuprofen uh and and somebody a fan of
the show called in
for some reason glenn close was being
discussed and he referred to as glenn
what's your nuts and uh
and believe it or not rudd shows walking
ibuprofen over glenn waternuts which is
a huge upset was the biggest upset of
week one of the nfl i mean everybody
thought the saints performance was a big
upset um so
what
have you drafted because you're in that
league with paul rudd right yes over
that league i have i have drafted it's
done um
it's done it's not i have number two
pick and so i i went with uh dalvin and
and so
my team name as it has been for a while
although i will take suggestions i could
i could change midstream uh it's just uh
get a load of these guys uh i it's just
straight out i like to just get it over
these guys you know
um nothing clever there's no problems
going on it just get over these guys i
mean what a what uh what a matchup must
be with you and carnavali get a load of
these guys versus just the tips i mean
that's got all sorts of
new york written all our like attitude
all over the place you know that's right
that's right so i i listened to bobby on
the shoulder last week whenever you had
them on about the parking and uh i have
the uh i have the luck of just hanging
in a hotel room right now so i i'm not
looking
and he was so proud of his did you see
this the photograph of him
jamming that didn't it i mean it's it
was
i wouldn't blame his his brooklyn
neighbor for staring at him and saying
you don't you can't get the car in there
i mean there's an inch on either side
there's an inch on he got the car in by
just the tip literally
that team name was born in that moment
i don't know if that's what he's i don't
think he's referring to parking but um
so all right so you like your team i
mean cook i like my team
i just uh
i got that you know devonte as well i
made a trade and got in got him and uh
you must have lost one though you must
have lost
uh i'm going with hurts you know it's a
14 team league so we got a lot but um
uh
yeah i feel pretty good you know okay
didn't didn't i took it on the chin this
week but uh high hopes
sunday what did rod go with dench
exclamation point again is his team
there was it a floral what is it called
a floral moment
for a moment yeah yeah it that's another
league i think this league he's okay
he's uh i think he's something called
flex avery which uh is an inside joke
that i i can't even explain flex
avery avery okay
i like it yeah you'll have to ask him
about that i will definitely do that
well when he's done you know saving the
planet for the marvel universe you know
that's
in london that's when that's when i'll
get in there all right and uh
anything else that you you want to talk
about that you've been doing that you've
been up to you want to throw anything
out there oh man well i just shot a
movie i just got a movie that i wrote
and directed uh up uh up in um idaho
doing a horror movie so i'm putting that
together an hour and post very excited
for people to see that i did i did a big
pivot from the comedy okay and i jumped
after something i've been want to do for
a long time so i'm excited about it i'm
excited for people to see it all right
well you'll come back on when it's time
for your movie to come out let's do that
in the meantime i'd appreciate it where
are you going is there a watch party are
you going to be
doing any live tweeting of tonight's
affair joe latrulio what do you got
we're going we're going over we're going
over seth meyers uh in a bit and um and
then i think we're we're we all saw the
finale already so um we're jumping on
the on the plane right after the show
but uh you know maybe we can stream it
again we can all watch it again on the
plane oh so you are okay so tonight what
you're all gonna make an appearance on
seth meyer's show
the cast you getting all together uh
yeah i think the
i think most of the cast will be there
yeah wow
nice that's so cool man just so yeah i'm
excited that is
a very it's a it's big day it's been
quite incredible uh run with this group
of people okay uh really proud of uh the
stuff that we
we did for eight years and uh i'm just
uh i'm i'm grateful have been a part of
uh all of it right did you save anything
from the charles boyle collection joe
quite i received uh a beige members only
jacket that was framed and put in a
display
is that real
hanging up with pride is that right
you're really a british member
that's right
that's right so you're saying somewhere
color base somewhere
somewhere in the nbc wardrobe department
they're like what happened to that beige
members only jacket they're like
wondering where that went
here
we'll have a great time tonight travel
safe brother we'll chat thank you so
much thanks for having me guys
that's uh the brooklyn nine-nine
one-hour series finale tonight at eight
eastern time on nbc joe latrulio a lead
pipe wielding professional dialing in on
time from a landline i mean that sounds
like he's sitting next to me yeah that
great
is the nbc is it probably a dirty rock
could be
could be hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here